[Music]
in this video we're going to show you
how to get the boolean Gemini which is
the exotic scout rifle that has taken
the place of the three four seven beste
dynasty the first thing you need to do
is finish the story missions then go and
plant all those beacons that sabalan
wants you to put down on the dreadmill
after that go to the reef and talk to
Petra she's then gonna give you a taken
war quest line that's specific only to
her you're gonna need to finish all the
quests in that quest line for Petra and
after that barracks will open up a new
quest line once you've acquired the
quest line from barracks go ahead and
finish all the steps in his quest line
as well it's not a hundred percent
confirmed that you have to do barracks
his quest line to get to the next step
but I would suggest doing it as this is
what worked for me
after you finished all of Eric's his
quests in his quest line head back to
Petra and she's gonna give you a
lost-and-found a quest or she wants you
to go into the dread-nots Explorer and
kill certain types of enemies after
slaying all the foes that she wants you
to slay and exploring what she wants to
check out go back to the reef turning
the quest and subsequently you should
receive your new shiny boolean Gemini
Scout right world